[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got raphael here with me
dude thank you so much for doing this
palm thanks for having me man absolutely
let's just get started with kind of your
background
um how do you and your co-founder end up
starting the company and kind of where
were you born and just
why yeah our origin story starts even
before you keir and i met
right uh you know both of us are
first-generation americans
uh our parents came to this country uh
looking for a better life
both of my parents are entrepreneurs
right they started her own business my
mom
was in the pharmacy business and started
her her own pharmacy my dad was in the
restaurant business
and both for you cure and i right ever
since we were kids uh we were working
with our parents right doing whatever it
took like
10 11 12 years old we had very
unorthodox
uh upbringings in terms of uh just
really really getting us encompassed
uh with business and uh being really
customer centric customer obsessed
um and delivering kind of financial
responsibility along the way
so my first day of college uh karen and
i went to drexel
i moved from north jersey moved from
south jersey which was a shorter commute
from him
and uh you know we met each other the
very first day and then immediately
connected right we immediately connected
because we shared the same values
we really understood one another we
worked together since we were kids
and uh it's it's something that just
literally made sense for us than day one
and we recognized that you know by our
second year that there's a pretty
glaring
uh need in the market right the in-store
experience
uh left a lot to be desired right no no
one wanted to go uh in store in college
and on-demand delivery services
uh or what we call in these third-party
platforms were anything but on-demand
right they relied on
the traditional infrastructure uh of
existing businesses to operate
which are good for to scale quickly but
not really great for
consumers or financial visibility so we
did something
you know kind of against conventional
wisdom we said if we're going to make
this work and kind of make money
alongside of it
uh we're gonna need to vertically
integrate we're gonna need to own all
the inventory
and uh and deliver to uh to end
consumers from our own micro fulfillment
centers
uh which at the time was not the best
idea right people were like uber and uh
and airbnb are starting to become very
big they're like you can't go on an
asset heavy model it doesn't work but
pressure just didn't make sense didn't
make sense to run any other model
uh so we did things a little differently
than kind of most bay area startups
right for first two years
we hadn't raised any money uh we
operated a profitable business from day
one
and then uh two years later after we
expanded to five cities of like four
additional verticals
outside of like the snack and drink
vertical we launched in
we raised our first uh our first dollars
our first bc dollars
which was the first dollars into the
business and then we went into complete
stealth mode
so for for three and a half four years
no pr
uh no outside of announcing no
fundraising announcements
uh we raised four rounds kind of in
between those four years
uh but we were just aggressively
expanding we went from
you know opening up uh like four or five
buildings uh a year to opening of 15 or
20 buildings a month
and we expanded to new categories no no
seeker we started as a college delivery
service but
you know we expanded to over-the-counter
medication and household and grocery and
pet and baby
and all these incremental new categories
uh
that kind of continue to grow and just
this past year we kind of uh
started telling our story to the world
we started telling you know you know
here we are
servicing 500 major u.s cities uh this
bevmo acquisition gives us the access to
the only state we don't really service
today
uh and it gives us access in a pretty
massive way
and we're just excited for what the
future has involved for us
so let's go back to the beginning um why
start a business rather than uh kind of
have one of the fleeting moments i feel
like everyone in college is always like
man
you know i wish x whatever that thing is
uh you guys took it further and actually
started the business
was it the upbringing was it just hey
i always knew i wanted to be an
entrepreneur like what was the the
reasoning behind actually wanting to
start the business
you have to i think uh
for kind of giving us the confidence
really early on as kids and instilling
us
all those values uh to kind of get it
off the ground
uh you know he actually started
in another startup earlier he's 17 years
old he had a company called qualified
gems
where he was selling juilliard online
he's doing a couple million dollars
before he entered college
so yeah he he had all this confidence
and his motivation to go solve this
problem
fortunately for us the problem that we
were solving uh was in the hundreds of
billions in the
total addressable market when we started
now in the multi-trillions
with all the incremental categories that
we entered into so not only did we solve
a problem that was really important for
our our own use case to solve we saw the
problem that was important for many many
others to solve as well
got it and so the idea of vertical
integration you already mentioned it
like
every business in the world over the
last 10 years has been obsessed with
asset light asset light how do i build a
marketplace right how do i do on demand
asset light
you took this opposite approach of how
do we vertically integrate how do we own
the inventory
what did you feel like you knew that
other people were missing or
why go kind of um against the grain and
do something that everyone else was
really
optimizing not to do
this a pump this is a hard business
right
this is uh you know opening up
warehouses getting liquor licenses
doing it like this is like the hard way
of expanding into uh
to what we call this instant needs
category uh but ultimately
it's it's not like an easy thing to
scale so a lot of people just
kind of push it to the side it's like
well i don't want to be in the business
of opening up micro fulfillment centers
and stocking inventory worrying about
supply chain and logistics
and then opening up more massive
distribution centers to support these
things
it's a lot easier to scale especially in
the beginning when you don't have to
deal with those things but as a
byproduct right these third-party
platforms have to monetize the gig
economy right so
make the spread of whatever they charge
uh the customer to
what uh the driver's take rate is for us
you know like
everything we draw we charge in delivery
fees which is a flat 195
plus the tip is a direct cost suite of
the driver we have no influence on the
service or delivery fees
we make our money on the on the gross
margin of the goods and fortunately for
us in our space and uh
and the price concept we're looking at
those gross margins are
very very healthy so our unit economics
as a by-product are super strong got it
and what was the decision behind
basically not talking to anyone about
any of this for three or four years
right you
again kind of bucked the trend everyone
else wants to brag about every single
fundraising round
uh literally they wake up in the morning
and they issue a press release uh
talking about how great they are
you did the exact opposite why
you know it kind of goes back right to
you know our origin story and
how fortunate we were to have really
great coaches around us from from day
one like
everyone that we had and to this day
that that coaches
and you know make myself and you cure
better
kind of continue to instill this cus the
customers the only thing that matters
mindset nothing else matters and like
as we looked at you know the value of
doing a press release over
a fundraiser that we just did right it's
it was more
ego driven than it was consumer driven
so it's like
the reason to do it is just to as you
mentioned right to tell the world how
great you are
which is nothing but bad right it
doesn't do any it doesn't it doesn't
provide any any real value
right for us right the reason we raised
the money was to get
gopro more available nationally faster
right make more products available
right and create more of these moments
that were important for our customers
so ultimately you know it did nothing
but drive
you know what we thought would drive ego
uh so we said
there's no reason to do that we're to
put the customer truly first
then this is something that we're just
not going to stand behind
got it and so how is the business going
so far you mentioned a couple of metrics
i don't know what you've shared publicly
but
how much capital have you raised who'd
you raise it from and how large has the
business gotten to today
yeah so the the business is growing very
very fast
all right uh we're opening like i said
we're opening roughly 15 to 20 of these
micro fulfillment centers a month
uh we're expanding very very rapidly in
the west coast
uh in in new york city uh which will be
a fun launch in the first half of next
year
uh uh new orleans and las vegas those
are the only metros that we're not in
in the us today and we have an
aggressive look at the suburbs
for next year as well we service 500
major u.s cities
uh today uh and the moments that we
expanded into right i
alluded to them earlier uh this
over-the-counter
medication category this household
category uh just pat and baby i never
thought
seven years ago when we started this
business that we'd be an authority in
the baby category
you know but here we are right you know
growing hundreds and hundreds of percent
year over year
uh in a category that's very very new
and we're looking to expand that even
more right we're looking to add even
more into that space
in terms of uh uh like fundraising we
raised
just shy of one and a half billion
dollars it allowed us to
kind of remain aggressive and continue
to open up uh
these uh these licenses and facilities
very very quickly
but i'll tell you like while we did that
all of that we really had financial
visibility and financial acumen in mind
as kind of step one
so if you look at our top markets today
so markets that are open for
over 18 months a hundred percent of
those cop markets are profitable
so it's like we built a model that's
really repeatable
we really focused on unnailing this
business model early on
right when we were profitable for our
first two years and then scaling it and
then exploding it
instead of kind of building on top of a
business model that was generating
losses
got it and so when you think through um
kind of the business model today
uh why go after these micro fulfillment
centers
and kind of the vertical integration can
be done many many different ways right
you even see
um maybe like a whole foods kind of a
really grand scale now they're testing
in new york city
uh the idea of turning their stores into
warehouses and really optimizing for
online
delivery what is kind of the strategy is
it just that you're more nimble you can
kind of service a
smaller radius around a micro
fulfillment center but you can have more
of them and therefore it cuts down on
time and cost or just walk me through
kind of
why micro fulfillment rather than maybe
just 10 across the country
um as the strategy so there's a
there's a number of uh of reasons behind
it uh
one of the things that's really
important is being able to own the
entire consumer experience end-to-end so
when you mess up right it's your own
fault it's not a delivery partner
uh that you know or or a merchant
partner that
uh kind of caused the break in the
consumer experience i think two
uh and really important to speed right
you wanna be able to place these things
very very close to to uh to your end
customers we've gotten really good at
mapping out the delivery zones outside
these micro fulfillment centers and how
many micro fulfillment centers we need
per city
you know some cities you know like uh
like a dallas has like
15 or 16 micro fulfillment centers today
to service uh
one given uh you know metro which is you
know plano and
all those surrounding areas but
ultimately for us
you gotta optimize to to be able to one
uh
be there where your customers are right
and two uh be able to deliver very very
quickly and own the entire experience
end to end uh in terms of you know your
marginal structure
right your marginal structure again
depends on you know what kind of good
you sell
and you know how well you buy to well
how well you sell and you know right now
we're we're very
comp to what people typically see in
store
uh like in you know whatever your local
cvs or your walgreens so it's typical to
what they see inside of an in-store
experience but still with a very very
healthy margin profile got it and walk
me through like what does a micro
fulfillment center
entail is this a warehouse that's kind
of on the edge of the city and people
are going in and out but it looks kind
of like
what people would envision as like an
amazon warehouse is it a you know
second story somewhere and literally
you've got delivery drivers running up
and down stairs like
what exactly does a micro fulfillment
center entail yeah that's our average
mfc is roughly a
000 square feet um it's usually in the
middle
of a city right you want to be as close
to the customer as possible right so
like
we have some in the outskirts to serve
the service like the suburbs uh
but predominantly these mfcs are in the
middle of u.s cities they're in the
ground level
uh they have you know way to get loading
uh they have liquor liquor enables in
them so like
in some in some cities uh where
regulatory it allows it's inside the mfc
in other cities it's right next to mfc
so we'll have a liquor store
uh and ultimately you know we position
these things to be as close to the
customer and to be able to continue to
expand
on these moments that are important for
our customers right next year
we're going to be launching quite a few
new verticals uh that we're really
excited about and we want to make sure
that
as we launch these new verticals we can
remain a one-stop shop for customers so
continuing to
kind of use uh vertical integration to
get into new categories that are
important for our customers
got it walk me through the decision as
to when you enter a new market like how
do you evaluate which markets are the
ones that enter and uh kind of
sequentially where do you go
yeah so we built uh something we call
gmat uh it's a gopro market optimization
tool uh
i think our team loves acronyms uh here
but
essentially it's a it's a model that
that uses kind of all the internal data
uh the uh what we call intent to
purchase so folks that are getting onto
the platform
trying to order go puff but it's giving
them a message that uh
uh that they can't order uh plus a bunch
of tapestry tools so lookalikes of like
what does uh what does a gopup customer
order look like today versus
to look at likes all over the country
and then i'll develop heat maps on
where to go and i can tell you like as
uh we've
grown and as our customer base has
developed those heat maps and those hot
like high areas have changed
dramatically right like our first two
years it was
you know predominantly college students
today you know some 15 percent of our
user bases college
so it the the user base has grown
tremendously
so it's uh it kind of we utilize that
data and use that regression model to
then
map where the next sites to enter into
got it and then walk me through the same
kind of analysis for new product
categories right when you want to add on
uh some of these verticals how do you
evaluate which ones are the next ones
you're going to add
yeah we go back to the customer right
like our number one way that we look at
it right we obviously have all
all the the market data uh but we'll
look at like failed search results right
like
something really simple and like hey
what are people searching for versus
you know their the results are not
populating well and sometimes that means
we're missing a certain skew that people
really really want that we don't carry
uh versus like you know we're missing a
whole category of goods that we need to
enter into in a very very big way like
you know before we were in the baby
category
uh a top five search term was diapers
right and we're like you know
you know do we really want to get into
the baby space
uh but then ultimately we let the
customer kind of uh
dictate for us right with the space we
need to be in and how do we continue to
expand
uh in this instant needs category so
you know ultimately for us we take a
first approach on on category expansion
and uh how do we believe it to be you
know an important strategy of what we do
absolutely walk me through the bevmo
acquisition in terms of
kind of how that came together and why
that was so attractive for you guys you
know bebo is really really interesting
uh one uh gopup as much as we've
expanded
uh we have not expanded into the fifth
largest economy at all
uh we're not in uh in california um
in in any way and uh when we evaluated
kind of the california expansion
it's either we continue to expand the
way that we expanded and
the regulatory framework in california
for alcohol is very very complicated
to kind of acquire liquor licenses or
we acquire a locally beloved brand that
already has all the infrastructure
for us to aggressively enter the state
um and there's really no comp to them
though
is a one-of-a-kind asset in in
california
that is really really loved by the
customers that it is four million
uh customers in their loyalty base and
uh you know the combination of that
their leadership team
and the infrastructure that we inherited
to be able to kind of enable
uh gopher's microfilm and strategy
within abevmo
uh really was uh with the decision to
enter and
ultimately give gopa uh to all of our
california customers
i love that reasoning uh in terms of the
actual business you're in most people
would think of this as oh they do food
delivery or they do goods delivery you
keep using the terminology
instant needs talk through what exactly
does that mean to you
and kind of why do you view it that way
rather than just
you know on-demand delivery or whatever
other terminology others would use
yeah that's a great question pump you
know for for us
uh we thought about like what are
immediate everyday needs that people
need
and again it started off as snacks and
drinks right that was the
the 2013 version of uh of instant needs
and it kept expanding so rapidly into
the other categories that people want so
like even though that
we play in this instant needs category
of continuing to deliver immediate
everyday essentials
uh to our customers we're going to
continue to expand and deliver things
from a one-stop shop basis so like
what's important to our customers and
what our customers keep telling us
is not only to be able to get these
products but to be able to get these
products bundled up into one order
so yeah i am in the mood for ice cream
but i also want toilet paper and laundry
detergent delivered to me right
and for that use case that's the
immediate everyday needs that's
important for them
so ultimately we're going to continue to
expand to those use cases that are
important for us again
utilizing our business model of you know
vertical integration to deliver it
inside of
performance centers so we don't have any
plans to kind of like you know partner
go and store pick up
that incremental need that someone wants
and then deliver it to them
we're going to continue to add them
within uh within our mfcs and uh and
deliver it to our consumers
absolutely and covet 19 obviously had
this massive impact in just society in
general everyone had to go sit at home
i'm assuming that that was a massive
tailwind uh to your business
what did you see in terms of uh kind of
earlier this year and into the end of
the year
with consumer either behavior changes or
just uh kind of affinity for
what you're doing what a ride 2020 has
been huh
you say that like somebody who spent
many nights not sleeping
yeah yeah that was uh it was it was it
was definitely
um definitely a lot of learnings right
so our business was growing triple
digits year over year
uh pre-code right we were already kind
of at a major accelerant
the business was developing and then the
covid was like an incremental shot of
adrenaline for us
right um all these new categories that
we entered into
uh saw growths you know up to like a
thousand percent year over year
right and uh in some of our newer
categories and development of them
especially kind of in the early months
of covid uh and even now right we're
still seeing a massive massive growth uh
year over year but
it was being able to adapt to that right
like we were one of the first uh
delivery companies to enable no contact
delivery
we provide ppe masks like i'm talking
about really early like in march
uh our tech team i don't think slept in
the month of april just developing tools
uh to really make sure that our drivers
operations associates and our customers
were safe
and we frankly did the best we could we
worked around the clock to really make
sure that everyone was safe
and to be able to continue to deliver an
amazing experience to our customer and i
think it really is a testament to our
team
how everyone came together um you know
especially the folks on the ground
especially our driver partners
especially our oas
uh they were kind of on the ground
making sure the customers didn't have an
interruption to service
yeah as you've built this you know
coveted 19 obviously is an accelerant
but you'd already built a great business
uh you're a relatively young guy
so is your co-founder obviously uh how
have the two of you kind of navigated
um building a large scalable business
raising you know over a billion dollars
and kind of just really i think taking a
home run swing if you will at an
industry that
one has a lot of competition but also
two is um
very obvious to people whoever wins uh
there will be
incredible kind of financial rewards and
um
kind of benefit to how do you navigate
that as a young
you know first-time founder i put first
time in kind of quotes in terms of just
like the first time building a really
scalable technology-enabled business
yep you know you definitely learned it
you can't do it by yourself right
we've uh you know in internally and
externally we surrounded ourselves with
people that
you know we call it 10xing right the
business is growing 3x year-over-year
you have to be 10xing yourself right
it starts with kind of all the coaches
that we have around us we've had
some really really amazing people that
have been able to 10x myself
and you cure as human beings uh kind of
year over year for the last seven years
and
have taken us to awesome heights and our
leadership team right
we know what we know and we know what we
don't know we've hired
a lot of really amazing people from all
over the world
uh to come in and help us really scale
this business whether it's figuring out
kind of the operational functions of
this business the supply chain functions
of this business
the marketing you know technology
product
merchandising the whole nine yards right
we have some of the best specialists
from all over the world
uh that are probably gonna solve these
problems day in and day out
and you can you kind of long learn along
the way but you know
in our opinion right the secrets tell us
as people and really making sure that
you know whether again whether it's a
tech issue
or an operational process issue or it
comes down to like
how good are your humans how well do
they culturally match with you
and then how do you scale you know our
business is not an easy business to
figure out we have a lot of moving parts
right we have you know this wms that we
built from scratch that powers
our micro fulfillment centers and the
bidding and batching technology
and then the routing technology to get
it to the driver all of it had to be
built kind of one step at a time
but it really came down to like the the
quality
uh both from a value match and you know
technical expertise perspective of the
people that we brought
got it and you've mentioned kind of
coaches a couple of times are these
investors who are acting as coaches are
they like executive coaches are they
just
people on an advisory board unpack that
a little bit for me
yeah i mean it's it's more like like
it's become
you know it was it started as something
formal and become something that's you
know like
where i'll give you an example uh
you know one of the guys who's taught me
uh
so much of what i know about
merchandising is this guy tom vellios
he's the
co-founder of a five below uh company in
the in the east coast and
uh you know he scaled three massive
businesses in his lifetime
uh he's i think tom is 30 or 35 years
older than me and one of my closest
friends
and uh has taught me a lot to this day
has continued to teach me a lot and
i have an analog to to tom in uh many
different spaces in the business whether
it's kind of the bd function or the
investment relations function
that helped like again 10x secure and i
right
we're pretty me and my co-founder like a
unit
we're both uh two halves of a single ceo
and uh you know ultimately all these
people that we've gotten on board
uh both investor and now an investor
have
really helped myself in nuclear scale
yeah i love that
uh in terms of the funding that you guys
just
took in what are you planning to do with
the money
you know for us it's like any other
fundraiser make go puff
more available to customers uh all over
the country we have this vision pop-up
being the world's go-to solution for
immediate everyday needs
right or we could be the world's go-to
solution we've got to be us's go-to
solution
and uh we have some work to do we have
some uh some kind of a
heavy lifting to do in california uh
from an integration perspective that's
starting
immediately um and we have three u.s
markets that we're not in we're not in
new york
we're not in las vegas and we're not in
new orleans we're planning to fix that
next couple months as well
so you know ultimately for us uh we want
to aggressively focus on
on the us uh this upcoming year and then
uh
go into achieving kind of a broader uh
you know
world's go-to solution uh as we then uh
start achieving
the us go to solution first what's the
thing that you could
envision five or ten years from now you
guys being involved in in terms of
whether it's a market category or
geography
that would be the most surprising to
people today
oh god uh i think services would be
would be
something that's really interesting
where i mean we're testing a lot of
things
with our cbg partners uh today i don't
want to divulge too much but uh that uh
that are really really exciting that are
it's out it utilizes vertical and
utilize our model but it's very
different than how people think about
gopro today
um and it's something that we're really
really excited about
we'll be piloting in the next couple of
quarters uh but that along
uh with three or four at least at least
three new verticals uh
launching in the first half of next year
stuff that we're really really excited
about
got it uh as the ceo you basically sit
there and you worry about three things
you worry that you've got enough money
in the bank you worry about all the
things that you're doing well and then
all the threats to the business
what do you see as the biggest threats
to the business in terms of you know the
next 12 to 18 months that kind of keep
you up at night or at least you're
thinking about
you know i used to you realize it's all
the same thing right like
you know six years ago i'd be like how
are we going to scale the operations
portion of this business or the supply
chain function
or how are we going to get engineering
leadership in philadelphia and like
really scale that and productly
but then you realize it's all like you
know people on an execution base right
it's like
are like can we out execute everyone
else can we get the right folks in place
right like
again lessons learned over seven years a
bad hire really sets you back months
uh so like to to this day you know you
care and i still every interview every
single hq employee right it's an entire
weekend
right going back and forth and really
really honing in and making sure that
this person that's joining in is the
right culture fit uh so for us it's all
about like
execution risks like we're two pretty
aggressive uh
co-founders that you know are moving
very very fast
and our ability to remain aggressive and
impress on the accelerator more
um is our biggest opportunity and risk
in this business
how has your relationship with your
co-founder changed over time people
always talk about
uh you know kind of you have the
quintessential story which i think
people love
is like hey we met in college first day
it was basically we knew that we were
gonna be friends
uh and now years later you've built this
massive business together
uh but it's not the same relationship
i'm assuming so how has that evolved
over time
you know you're pretty different right
um
you know you cure uh is a natural
introvert who's becoming more who's
become more extroverted over the years
i'm an extrovert who's become more
introverted over the years um
but i'd be hard-pressed to find two
other people that have internal values
that are more alive than nature and i
right like we spend 17 hours a day
together which my fiance thinks is a
little weird but
you know it it is it is what it is right
like we're here in florida we're in the
the same house together
uh we live in the same apartment
building we just bought two houses in
philadelphia that are right next to each
other like
we are very very very close uh
closer tonight i think i know anyone
else to be
and you know you chair and i get into a
lot of arguments with other people where
we're very passionate when it comes to
our customers
but we very very rarely argue with one
another because we're
so aligned on how we see the world and
then ultimately how we see this business
developing
so i think the biggest gift uh that
college
gave me was a cure right it wasn't like
you know this education go up everything
right
is amazing but the foundation was us
founding finding each other and then
being able to be so aligned to
create such a great business and uh be
able to have the privilege of scaling it
is there a story that kind of highlights
one time where you guys did disagree and
how you were able to kind of
figure out where the common ground was
because it's interesting
um you know i've got four younger
brothers and i'm assuming that your
relationship
uh with him is very similar to almost a
brother where uh
you get in arguments but you always know
at the end like hey love you and you
know tomorrow we're gonna be fine
uh any stories there that that kind of
highlight how that's played out for you
guys
yeah um you know we
uh we entered new york uh as our state
market before we raised any money and um
you know we were feeling good about
ourselves right we were feeling good
that we figured out this model we were
freaking good that we
figured out product market fit you know
it's kind of like a high almost right
like
everything is going right and then
something goes terribly wrong right uh
we entered new york where we were
grossly unprepared to be in new york we
were
the company with seven people um it was
it was pre-funding we actually ju we
were just raising was the middle of us
raising our round
and we desperately wanted to make new
york work right and new york just
required technology and capabilities
that the 2014 year old versions of
ourselves just didn't have
and you know i was very stubborn
about making it work i was very stubborn
because we had so much customers and we
were making work and our customers loved
us
it just was by by the point we decided
to shut it down and
now we opened it years later uh we had
already been in 14 more markets but new
york was taking more time than
under 13 combined together and you're
kind of like was like
i don't know why we're doing this i
don't know why we continue to hit our
head against the wall
we're not able to scale it's really a
crutch
and uh yeah it kind of stands out as a
place where it's like we kind of
went at each other and like we got to be
there and then ultimately he was right
he was right um you know leaving new
york was the best thing that we did
as much as it pains me because i i grew
up in brooklyn uh
but you know ultimately now we're so
much better prepared right we're because
i don't even recognize the 2014 year old
version of uh
of our company uh but we were grossly
under
unprepared to enter a market and i think
if we continue to bang against the head
against the wall in new york
we would have been in a much different
position today so it's like in that case
two heads was much better than one
uh we kind of came together uh we hash
it out ultimately i think made the best
decision for the business
uh and now can enter new york in a much
more aggressive fashion
how was fundraising during uh kind of
this pandemic
era i'm assuming most of it was over
zoom and
and was it any different than the other
fundraising rounds you guys have done
uh or anything worth uh kind of talking
about there
so for us uh this latest round uh
was kind of co-led by an existing
investor and a new investor for the
existing investors right
you know them very well and they're like
kind of seeing how the business is
transforming they're like
i'm like holy [ __ ] right this is
literally on fire
grown so much uh kind of not month or a
month a week over week
uh and we got a lot of action from from
other
folks right a lot of people were
noticing how much this business was
growing
and for us you know just like you know
employees right
it's really important that you really
culturally
vibe with the person that that's going
to be with you right raising money is
like a
marriage that you cannot divorce you got
to be really certain that like these
people that you're bringing into
into the fold uh really have the same
vision for the organization as you do
and uh for us d1 had that same vision
right uh dan heim's great
great guy ekira was spending a lot of
time with them uh
and ultimately for us that was like
predominantly like a zoom and phone call
thing but
we still have to be sure that like these
are our guys for scale
and i think they uh they enjoyed the
performance that we've had over the last
couple years
and uh the the kind of model that we
built but we had a lot of guys on the
table ultimately being very very
selective on uh on who we wanted to
bring into the fold
what's the number one thing that you've
learned since you started the business
right i'm sure there's a million things
but in your mind like what's like the
thing that sticks out as
uh this was either the most important
lesson the thing that surprised me the
most from when i started to today
yeah you know young founder we i think
we try to do it all right like
try to do everything uh yeah i i still
only sleep like five
six hours a night right like it used to
be a lot less but you know we're still
seven days a week
she cares about oh this is all we really
know
uh but if we had started hiring earlier
and started really bringing on the
talent that we brought on like
2015 16 and beyond like two years prior
i think we would have been even more
ahead so like again going back to
you know you know the the thing that i
learned biggest lesson was
was all around people and the kind of
people that you bring on board and
really making sure culturally you're
building the right organization
uh so we spend a lot of time on kind of
rethinking that we're thinking about
you know what our core values look like
what is the personality
of like you know we call it a team
oriented super athlete right
and the super athlete became table
stakes since there's so many lessons
learned kind of along the way from a
cultural standpoint
uh but it's what helps you kind of move
at warp speed
right it's what helps you launch
business units that take others nine
months and
30 days um and ultimately getting those
right group of individuals
was uh the most painful lesson i think
we learned early on because i think that
organization would have been much bigger
than what it is today
you know no regrets right all learnings
and kind of
meaningful steps forward but the secret
sauce is definitely people
as you've experienced kind of covid
there's been lots of benefits to the
business but obviously it kind of forced
everyone home
uh were there changes to the culture or
things that you guys did to
to kind of ensure that uh everything
kind of ran the way that you wanted it
to run even though
uh people weren't coming into the office
as often
yeah so um ultimately we continue to do
the things that were
were important uh for for go pop right
every week mini chair addressed the
whole company
uh we made sure we over indexed in uh in
team meetings so you
and i were were present at all those
things but it really came down to the
leadership we had in the org as a whole
and really really making sure we're over
aligned with our leadership team
so on the leadership team basis we went
from you know having one-on-ones
obviously with all of our leaders
uh every single week and kind of on a uh
on a
less formal basis to meeting with the
lte team every single day
right there's there's time on the on the
calendar for one hour every single day
to really make sure
we're overly aligned we're overly
transparent we're overly thinking about
it
and then with a whole org every single
friday so we spend a lot of time on
really making sure we're over
communicate it's not like the same thing
where you can
just walk in the head of your bd's
office you know
chat aggressively with him for 10
minutes and leave right
it's uh you got to really make sure
you're you're over correcting for that
so that's what we did and you know even
on the on the non-business side
we recognized that as gopa was doing
really well others weren't right so we
partnered with
dozens and dozens of local businesses
putting their products into go puff
some of which we heard from from their
owners later would not have survived
uh without government you know it's a
really really amazing feeling internally
to now
one give locally beloved products the
customers we love but also help
uh uh organizations that were kind of
feeling the other side of the pandemic
and
their business affected in a very
adverse way where'd the name go puff
come from
i wish uh i wish i could tell you like a
really remarkable story or like
it is uh it's not it's not as exciting
right
it's a name that really intrigued
interest uh among our friends
uh in college i gotta tell you right
it's a name that our customers
love today right we talk a lot about our
customers about the name and uh
the transit the name and you know today
millions of
users uh that are using the the platform
it's a name that our customers really
love and a name that really intrigues
them
so ultimately uh it's it's something
that we thought of in college right
again no secret uh this business started
in college
uh but it's a name that attracts a whole
host of new customers today
uh again less than 15 percent of our
user base
today's college the most important
question i'm gonna ask you today is
are you still having fun i think i'm
having more fun now than ever before
right i can't i can't imagine doing
anything else right again i have no
other hobbies
uh this is this is it for me
right uh i love it i'm doing it with
another human uh that i love he cures
like really like a brother to me
and uh the kind of folks that we have on
board you know
i'd be hard-pressed to find uh another
lte team and another
management team like ours i'm really
excited for
for what uh the next weeks and months
have ahead and
ultimately getting out of 20 and 20 and
uh going into 2021 really strong
i love it uh i always ask everyone the
same two questions to end it and then
you'll get asked me one as the
as the final thing first question is
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
uh uh this one uh this one is easy uh
it's trillion dollar coach
uh i don't know if uh if you read that
one
it's a great one yeah it's one that i
really really love
uh and uh i see a lot of analogs in my
own life
on uh on on that book and ultimately
how uh how that book has shaped
uh the lives of so many people um in
silicon valley and otherwise
absolutely second question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i think i think aliens exist we had this
it's funny we talked about this last
night at two in the morning with the
cure
what was the debate your cure is hard no
on aliens a heart like he's like there's
no there's no there's like there's no
[ __ ] aliens in the world that's it i
don't believe it
you can't convince me i'm like i feel
like there's aliens
i'm glad you're the one who came on the
podcast then because uh i don't need any
uh anti-alien people to uh keep
spreading that nonsense i'm waiting no
no no i think there's aliens out there
for sure
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me uh
you've been doing this for
for two years right yep what is
the biggest surprise for you man what's
the number one thing uh the biggest
insight you could give me
i think everyone's way more similar than
they are different for sure
and if i had to really boil down you
know all these successful people
and uh entrepreneurs investors that come
on uh
there's no secret to success like you
just gotta do the work
um and that's like sounds pretty simple
but people kind of lose sight of that
and then the second the second thing i
think is um
and you actually said it earlier is like
you can't do it alone right it really is
uh every single person who comes on and
tells a story of success
uh will explain whether it was their
parents
whether it was family members friends
investors
coaches colleagues whatever it is
there's always
um a multitude of people in their life
uh who kind of helped them along the way
and uh
you know every story is different but
they all have those common traits and so
when you just hear it over and over and
over again after talking to hundreds of
people you're like
you know what this thing isn't really
that complicated the hard part is
staying kind of
persistent and disciplined and just
doing it for years and years and years
and i think
you know your story is a perfect example
of that of you know as you get kind of
seven eight ten years into a business
you start to realize like we know what
to do it's just an execution and people
thing
right and so i think that you're spot on
and obviously the results speak for
themselves so far
got a long way to go long way to go
we're just getting started here
love it where can we send people to uh
find you on the internet or find more
about go puff
get download the app and uh just go up
on the app store google play or go to
gopub.com
all right are you on the internet
anywhere or are you hiding yeah just
raphael i have a long russian last name
illusion uh you can find me instagram
twitter i'm all over
all right man listen thank you so much
for doing this i'll do it again in the
future
thanks so much